una imagen que ya es historia una
delegación del gobierno de colombia ya
está en cuba para realizar los primeros
acercamientos con la guerrilla de ln la
visita ha estado liderada por el
canciller álvaro leyva y el alto
comisionado para la paz danilo rueda el
ejecutivo de gustavo petro ha arrancado
con fuerza en su primera semana presentó
un proyecto de reforma tributaria
restableció relaciones con venezuela e
inició los acercamientos con el ln el
propio petro habló del propósito de la
visita y entonces la labor de danilo en
este momento es
auscultar
en la máxima extensión posible de la
violencia en colombia hasta donde es
cierta la posibilidad de procesos de paz
de acogimiento a la justicia en muchos
casos colombia firmó un acuerdo de paz
con las farc en 2016 era la guerrilla
más grande y antigua de américa latina
el gobierno de juan manuel santos
también mantuvo conversaciones con el l
en estas se estancaron en 2018 con el
gobierno de iván duque son más lentas
como explicó el experto víctor de currea
lugo para france24 uno de los grandes
mitos que se maneja hereden está
dividido no llc una concepción
asamblearia de su organización y esto le
plantea estar haciendo consultas por eso
mientras la par negociaban de una manera
directa por pies comandantes estaban
allí la delegación de diálogo del tacto
rtl n tienen que venir a colombia para
hacer consultas fundado bajo ideología
marxista-leninista lln cuenta con
alrededor de 2.300 efectivos tiene
presencia tanto en colombia como en
venezuela donde es uno de los grupos
armados más poderosos